okay guys we're back we're back what has
happened nothing really
you made this wire entrapment like a
last episode we got a magnet Nets string
it made a magnet that's my shrink so now
we are going there good as a mouse it's
reaching a general store we haven't
checked out a lot of stuff actually yes
we can make the giant loop well let's
check out the door no more you know Carl
oh yeah forget about this it's fricking
music
let me just figure out I think I have to
make a right
just check I can't go I think it's gonna
be alive
and you can see share mezack they drive
at the same time
maybe in my right oh my sadness Jana
[Music]
loading screens
it is a beautiful yeah I got that man no
I think I can get I forgot I think I can
get past by just going around here
it's
felt at the store and its surrounding
still out there and he didn't like to
miss out now
yes I was missing out
I think it was the first two stars
they say but the game's over sooner they
like finish everything like visit every
place let's check what check
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] whitening
- there's a mailbox right here
I know why there's a mailbox right here
there's nothing big here
right
access
is there a house here
[Music]
I can still check it out really quick
give you something a chainsaw oh there's
a [ __ ] house up here but chances
house and they're bad oh [ __ ]
lads can't let you jump
the air was freezing right down okay is
that sir
if ISS the other-worldly ice had struck
again
Wow i shat woman's hopes and dreams were
frozen in eternity
okay technically was hidden under the
stairs [ __ ] is this
the man grabbed his rifle Karl felt a
sense of dread in him I see that inspect
Bertrand 1948
perhaps their relationship it seems like
secrecy was commonplace allies and all
that was left of her voice was a diary
she confided in this diary
amongst other things the tragic story of
a young woman a victim the combination
was hiding okay
father's first initial three numbers had
been great behind his pending
what skills father's name
his father's fault my three numbers had
the agreement okay
I can't say sit out here looks like they
repaint the whole house
I can arrange it there unpack boxes
suggest they just moved here okay
looks like the holes in that puzzle are
there to stay
just sound yeah they're not there is
hair good
and the pot was cold and the stew inside
wasn't cooked sat down like that for
Giselle was slow-cooked before she got
snuffed what a waste
[ __ ] lights in this house though hey
guys lights okay table shows lot of
things here how that is closing on me
that window had seemingly been left open
for a while Carl thought you have given
the punishing weather it couldn't have
been intentional the general store along
with several more infrastructures in the
area had been acquired by wealthy
industrialist William Jay Hamilton
perhaps the village should be
rechristened Amal town it felt like old
people where all these walls could see
for years the LeChase is clear hardly be
blamed for wanting to freshen things up
a bit
many box lock says about Carl didn't
need to summit his detective training to
quickly figure that the lush houses had
just moved in open the safe
arrest the pandas clearly there was some
major revamping work underway here the
place looked barely habitable I found
many boxes scattered about Carl didn't
need to summon his detective training to
quickly figure that the lush houses had
just moved in beautiful portrait of Jill
and Giselle bound together by the chains
of conventional law
many boxes scattered about Carl didn't
need to summon his detective training to
quickly figure that the lush houses had
just moved in
there's nothing here
everything is something if I don't
what's in here that's safe just a
[ __ ] diary three numbers behind the
pendant
panting okay I guess that's it nothing
house here
that guy's good check out [ __ ]
I can pendant
hey back here is
okay keep that phone down here
the [ __ ]
ya know but I didn't trick and call out
here man ma honey back all right let me
just step inside to save cuz a lot went
on that house safer
ten years
I said Laurel was becoming increasingly
convinced that this was not normal
hunting
the game that was being tracked was
fearsome so much so that the hunter
didn't dare approaches okay
say where's the next place that
pretty much gotta make a right and then
should be round left
[ __ ] [ __ ] horrible driving
get help because gonna work on this
whether it's bad
my dad's house shits call that here what
was even the point of locking your door
if everyone hit their key in the same
place
Carl was trying to feel like his
investigator LifeLock challenged the
house smelled like incense the kind that
reminds you of the good Lord of peace
now its chance religion was very
influential throughout Quebec many years
ago indeed it was surprising that Carl
did not come across a single Chapel
since arriving here
[ __ ] here yes the perfect cookie cutter
Catholic family most likes on sending
church every Sunday Master who knew that
giraffes thrived in the North Pole the
craze for toys was stupefying of
religion and ancestors was rude to deep
inside the hearts of canadians of old to
which the bards appeared to be closely
related
that's a chef in here the [ __ ] a
LightSwitch in your house
crazy
Vader's had without a doubt bin the
closest man in the village to William
Hamilton otherwise known as Uncle Willie
[Music]
father
okay thank you nothing in here except
the closes games mr. Hammond I think
I've ever found Carl wasn't desperate
enough to invade a village woman's
privacy Carl wasn't desperate enough to
invade after lips woman's private
Chicago
cold mystery chances
Bannack
take it Sarah Sarah huh
further north
now there are photos
oh yeah where's that gills did cows cows
gaskets
yes
okay yeah that's all I know so [ __ ]
lame in here
you will not believe her lips oh my god
I can see kisses light bright kid has no
[ __ ] lies at all the family's mother
must have spent her days washing the
filth off her kids diapers
our TVs on the other side scary
okay I check this side what is that up
there
that's just tree
that radio that
an aging car was perfect hey grab the
notary's heavy sand was a huge backseat
large enough always strives the lonely
temptations at bay
obviously Karl thought someone in this
house wasn't doing a good job at
upholding the holy Bible's teachings
okay
see where I got next exit make it right
turn
it's if we can program at the phones
let's say
[Music]
letting screen ready
[Music]
[Music]
what a night
holy [ __ ] don't have any wood now what
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I take out
I gotta make some more see the talking
in here now
we flooded too dangerously people live
in here
let's go away
it was a classic Canadian house except
for the absent horde of kids that would
normally be swarming about one more move
and white is checkmated game over
it seems the game was abandoned right
before the final strike came down
there's that matches that is that the
seven matches all shares a lot of
[ __ ] matches
Oh guys
yeah
are charged with nothing
[ __ ] not a single weapon was left all of
them were gone
kenapa lane
all manners of clothing were gone as if
the laws drove at his town with their
closet
or anything else here
okay back into the [ __ ] first dance I
think okay where am i where am i gonna
be left out of here
yeah
and I'm talking shortcuts in this cancer
you really get it right now [ __ ] fast
got a fast travel again the car that's a
fast job
okay
shut up somewhere I guess
I like to touch it with using our versa
a lot of things
[Music]
this is the first time right okay
just tells you where you are it's that
good thank God
now just okay
in spite of dr. bull praise Goodwill
it's the place didn't look much like a
physician's office it could easily be
mistaken for a sewing shop there should
be a law forbidding doctors from falling
sick
I mean a Communist Manifesto only a few
years ago this type of Allegiance meant
prison time and even at present the
Western world was very wary of the
Soviet threat why would the doctor own
such a book that's fortunately for Carl
inspecting it wouldn't further this
particular investigation
[Music]
Carl got the trembles as he imagined the
excruciating pain that kind of scalpel
could no doubt inflicted in these
miserable balls patrons probably felt
more like in a slaughterhouse than their
doctor's office for the one-eyed or for
other vision problems the eye patch was
the way to go the good doctor was it dr.
Bo pate who had hit him head on it the
village bothers nobody kills a rich
patient to start a revolution it didn't
make any sense he had to dig deeper
still to understand luckily that was
Carl Faubert specialty there was no
doubt that the doctor and Hamilton knew
each other very well someone had lost a
few liters of blood here Carl's first
thought had been a lumber accident
someone's hand cut by a saw or a hunting
accident in any case whoever had lost
all this blood couldn't have gone far
perhaps they were already dead
okay it's coming inside just that
trigger the thing
you all lumber yeah
Carl felt like he knew the doctor now
his belongings had spoken lengths about
him what Carl had heard
like so much
[Laughter]
sighs I should make out
[Music]
my house well safe
for a second
as I forgot to shatter your [ __ ]
Drive we can drive
sit here I think so much [ __ ] land
again locked
I'll check this out oh it's [ __ ]
freezing I should hear it but they have
a beautiful
I shot someone [ __ ] [ __ ] on us
she met another boy Escondido Josh's
compressor my pop you chose leticia
ordaz would look
see judo Jiu Li Shu basket eiv you can
weaken them is a funny one but it's rare
to see Marie
I mean that we go malleable holes
lecture you kids don't know your
iniquities what you believe look silly
[ __ ] civilization could common chasm
alphabet in Banbury cetera but now I
didn't shows that will be a comparison
you know recently you terrible
I hate care about one okay
well that'd be the next episode tracking
down the care by wine I'm pretty sure we
got it at the general store what's out
here
over here
I go all right well will you buy that
out of there now thanks for watching
yeah this was the interesting story
you're watching guys see ya the next one